[Music]
the movie starts in a nightclub where
two ladies are chatting near the bar one
of the girls annie approaches a peculiar
looking man and convinces him for a
dance moments later while the two are
enjoying their time the man suddenly
grabs annie and kisses her passionately
for about five minutes surprisingly she
experiences an orgasm just from the kiss
and quickly excuses herself when she
returns back to the dance floor the man
is nowhere to be seen a confused dany
then joins her friend and reveals that
she's experiencing a weird sensation in
her body she even gulps down a glass of
vodka in one go and finds it sweet the
next day annie is in a very good mood
because of last night's encounter she
heads to her workplace a kindergarten
school and starts teaching the students
with high enthusiasm all of a sudden her
vision starts getting blurred and she
falls unconscious in the evening she
wakes up in a hospital bed where the
nurse mentions that she has become
pregnant this shocks annie to the core
as she has been infertile all her life
as her uterus is damaged it gets even
weirder as she hasn't had any
intercourse than the last four months
hearing her worries the doctor conducts
an ultrasound test and confirms that she
is actually pregnant as annie stares at
the screen and bewilderment it finally
dawns on her that the kiss from the
previous night is responsible for all
this maybe it was the orgasm that did it
but if a woman had to orgasm in order to
become pregnant our world would be a lot
less populated following this the movie
cuts to a few days back where the same
strange man from the nightclub ren is
flying a spaceship looking at the
advanced mechanism inside the spaceship
it is evident that the man is an alien
he has all the details on annie and is
heading towards earth to meet her here
we get to know that he's going to earth
because his planet is dying and all the
women have become extinct there hence
his mission is to impregnate earth's
women starting with annie the strange
thing is that on his planet everyone
reproduces using their mouth just then
ren notices a large spaceship on the
radar and an alarm goes off but before
he can react the large spaceship starts
bombarding him with lasers this goes on
for a while and just as the large
spaceship is about to destroy the small
one with a missile lightning strikes the
two both the spaceships immediately lose
control and they crash to earth after a
while ren comes out of the wreckage and
starts heading to his destination at the
same time we are formally introduced to
annie who is a divorced woman she lives
alone in her house but usually gets
calls from her ex-husband jack a
high-ranking police officer who is still
in love with her the reason for their
divorce is revealed to be annie's
infertility that night she heads to a
nightclub and enjoys her time as shown
in the first scene of the movie however
the night ends strangely for her when
she gets kissed by the alien ran and
becomes pregnant the next day after
annie returns home from the hospital she
is again approached by red from outside
the door ren mentions that he wants to
talk urgently but she becomes scared and
tells him to go away however since ren
is on a mission he is adamant on talking
suddenly annie starts having
contractions and she rides in pain
taking this as an opportunity wren
breaks open the door and enters the
house he tries calming a scared annie
but as expected she threatens to call
the police she even picks up an iron rod
and starts swinging it causing the whole
room to get trashed when ren fails to
convince her he simply takes out one of
his high-tech alien devices and uses it
on annie rendering her unconscious after
this he kidnaps her from the house the
next morning he brings her to a secluded
spot and finally tells her everything he
introduces himself as ren and reveals to
annie that the baby she is carrying
belongs to him he further mentions that
he is an alien who has traveled all the
way from another galaxy to impregnate
earth's women as his population is on
the verge of extinction unsurprisingly
annie doesn't believe a word he is
saying but when ren makes a small cut on
his hand and reveals his white blood she
begins to believe after this he mentions
that they do not have much time left as
one of his enemies has followed him to
earth and he will eliminate annie and
their child at any given chance the
enemy is of the same alien race that has
decimated his population to near
extinction saying this ren urges annie
to come with him to his spaceship as it
is their only hope of escaping the enemy
this is why i don't go clubbing
meanwhile the other alien who has taken
up the alias williad is on the hunt for
annie his mission is to stop her from
giving birth to ren's baby shortly after
he reaches her house and starts going
through her things when he notices
annie's pet cat he picks it up and uses
his alien powers to see through its
memory the cat had witnessed wren
forcefully taking away annie so williard
also gets the memory he probably also
gets memories of lots of butt licking he
then sets off to find the duo and
eliminate them once and for all after a
while annie's ex-husband jack arrives at
the house and is terrified to see its
state he immediately assumes that annie
has been kidnapped and orders his men to
initiate a search operation in the area
when he reaches the police station he
receives information about the
mysterious man who kissed annie at the
nightclub just then willard arrives at
the place and introduces himself as a
bounty hunter from chicago he claims
that he has captured ren before and
knows a great deal about him so the
police should let him join in on the
search operation however jack refuses
the request and leaves elsewhere as ren
and annie are traveling through the
woods the latter feels a sudden pain in
her stomach and falls to the ground
seeing this ren takes out a strange
medication from his bag and feeds it to
her this immediately takes her pain away
and he is surprised as to why she is
experiencing such pain in just her
second day of pregnancy to which ren
replies that his species can give birth
to new offspring in just three days
after a while jack along with some of
his men reached the same forest where
ren and annie are hiding as they're
scanning through the area using sniffing
dogs willard suddenly approaches from
behind expectedly jack becomes angry and
threatens to arrest him but the other
cops suggest they let willard stay as he
is the only one who knows about red
hesitantly jack agrees and the group
continues their search in the meantime
as ren and annie camp in the woods ren
starts explaining about the condition of
his planet he mentions that one day
willard and his race suddenly invaded
his planet and started a genocide which
killed almost 99
of their entire population they were
more powerful intelligent and advanced
so they couldn't be stopped ren and some
others managed to escape the onslaught
but by this time the female population
on the planet had become extinct i guess
the men all left the women behind when
they ran away hence wren took the
initiative and traveled to earth hoping
that a similar species humans could help
him breed an offspring hearing all this
annie inquires as to why she was chosen
to which ren replies that she has a
damaged uterus and that is perfect for
bearing an alien child the next morning
while ren is scavenging the forest for
some supplies annie makes a run for it
unfortunately she comes across willard
completely oblivious to the fact that he
is the killer alien willard promises to
take her to a safe place but suddenly he
draws out a gun and points it at her as
he is about to finish her off one of the
police officers spots him and fires at
him willard is shot in the arm but
despite this he manages to kill the
officer meanwhile a terrified annie is
seen running through the woods when she
bumps into ran she tells him everything
about the incident and hearing this ren
deduces that willard has arrived to kill
them he then requests annie keep going
as time is running out for them on the
other hand willard uses his regeneration
powers to heal his gunshot wound which
appears to be leaking a purple liquid
shortly after jack and the other
officers approach him and ask what
happened being the cunning alien that he
is willard puts the blame on ran and
mentions that he killed an officer
before escaping with annie a few hours
later as the police group continues
searching for the kidnapper willard
reveals the true identity of red he
mentions that ren is an alien who has
traveled from another planet to save his
race from extinction his main mission is
to breed with annie and take the
offspring back to his planet where they
can reproduce further and multiply the
population the information stuns jack
and his group elsewhere annie and ren
enter a motel to take some rest at this
moment annie has become extremely weak
and the baby is almost ready for
delivery ren calms her down and reveals
that he has started liking her he also
mentions that she resembles his late
wife who was brutally killed by willard
and his race one thing leads to another
and the two end up kissing again and
surprisingly this reduces annie's pain
later the couple rent a car and continue
their journey to the spaceship however
jack and his group arrive out of nowhere
and start chasing them willard who is
also in the car suddenly takes out a
rifle and starts shooting at annie much
to jack's horror because of this the
police car gets imbalanced and falls
into a ditch allowing ren and annie to
escape following the accident an enraged
jack gets out of the car and beats up
willard he then cops him to the police
car and calls the station unit for
backup after a while he heads off to
search for his ex-wife along with
another officer leaving willard alone on
the other hand ren and danny reached the
spaceship crash site but the former is
devastated to see that it has been
destroyed since the spaceship could
regenerate itself he had expected that
it would be perfectly operable by now
but because of the earth's polluted
environment it instead disintegrated why
didn't willard's arm disintegrate then
as the two contemplate their next move a
couple of police officers arrive at the
scene and shoot ren in the leg annie who
at this point has started liking the
alien tries to make the cops understand
that willard is the actual villain but
they do not listen instead they load the
couple in a car and head towards the
police station sadly their journey is
short-lived as willard who easily
escaped custody stops them midway and
starts shooting both of the officers are
immediately killed but ren manages to
save annie he then cleverly unlocks his
handcuffs picks up a revolver and shoots
willard several times momentarily
subduing him taking this as an
opportunity the two get in the car and
escape while willard regenerates himself
later as ren is brainstorming ideas on
how to get back to his planet he
suddenly remembers that some of the
senior members of his race possess
telepathic powers with these powers they
can track their family members on other
planets hence he mentions that all they
have to do is reach a high mountain from
which he can release signals and summon
a spaceship and he responds that the
highest place in the city is jackson
hills a place she used to visit
regularly when she was a child hearing
this ren immediately starts driving
towards the place in the next scene the
duo reach the end of the road and decide
to continue their journey in a cable car
when they reach midway annie's water
suddenly breaks and she goes into labor
as she screams in pain ren uses his
alien-like skills and successfully
delivers the baby which turns out to be
a daughter excellent now every alien of
that species can reproduce with her with
this annie has given birth to a baby for
the first time in her life despite being
infertile in the meantime jack has
followed the duo's abandoned car and is
searching the area in a helicopter
willard is also at the same location and
as soon as he sees the helicopter he
starts shooting at it causing it to
retreat after a while he reaches the
spaceship's landing spot and starts
searching for annie but to his surprise
he encounters ren who is determined to
finish him off the two then engage in an
intense fight but since willard is
stronger he easily subdues ren and
shoots him several times seemingly
killing him then he heads out in search
for annie and finds her hiding behind an
electric generator willard climbs the
generator and is about to kill her but
just then ren who appears to be alive
uses the last of his strength and
activates the generator using his device
this causes a massive electric shock
which finally kills willard after the
enemy is defeated annie rushes to wren
who is taking the last breaths of his
life she hands him over their daughter
so that he can see her one last time at
the same time jack also arrives and
immediately embraces his ex-wife
although he is in disbelief due to the
entire incident he still decides to help
ren up onto his feet just then the
spaceship arrives and lands nearby some
aliens emerge from it and thank annie
for her valuable contribution but before
they can provide medical attention to
ren he passes away the movie ends as the
aliens take the infant and ren back to
their planet while annie and jack wish
them goodbye from afar and annie is
traumatized forever subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching